[Music]
do you get
a little nervous before a flight
if you do you're not alone between
33 and 40 of people feel some form of
anxiety when they board a plane
while a giant metal object flying
through the air stuffed with people and
cargo
sure sounds precarious planes are
actually pretty steady not convinced
let's do an experiment here we have a
boeing 777
it's a full flight and we're going to
make all 500 passengers
jump at once how much force would that
exert
[Music]
what is natural frequency
and why are sandbags used on a plane
this is what if and here's what would
happen if
all the passengers on a plane jumped at
once
you are one of 500 passengers on our
boeing 777
it happens to be the flight captain's
birthday and the flight attendants want
to pull a little prank
they whisper the plan to everyone as
they pass out complimentary snacks
you are a little unsure of this prank
but
hey everyone else looks unfazed what's
the worst
that could go wrong balanced weight
is extremely important for the safety of
an airplane
an improperly loaded plane can be
dangerous
it's not just too much weight that you
have to worry about but
also too little when planes don't have
enough passengers and cargo
people have to be moved around the cabin
to properly distribute weight
sometimes a flight crew will even have
to add sandbags weighing
23 kilograms each so
what happens when a bunch of weight is
displaced for
just a second well let's get back to our
flight and see
the airplane has reached altitude and
the seat belt light turns off
all the passengers including you rise
from their seats
the tallest people make their way to the
isle where there's a little more
headroom
you place your hands on the headrest of
the seat in front of you to stabilize
yourself the flight attendant gives the
signal
and everyone jumps as people's bodies
leave the floor of the cabin
the plane loses 37 500 kilograms of
weight
because the plane is lighter it will
rise in altitude
as passengers leave the floor together
you and the other passengers exert the
force
of about 10 elephants or 800 people
this sudden push of weight changes the
plane's trajectory and the captain
loses control as the plane nose dives to
your untimely death
wait that doesn't sound right rewind
this sudden push of weight changes the
plane's trajectory and
nothing really happens because the plane
is traveling at around
870 kilometers per hour this collective
jump only
created a minor change in trajectory the
captain
can easily adjust though he may be a
little annoyed at all his pesky
passengers
now this is assuming that all 500
passengers have
an average weight of 75 kilograms for a
total weight of
37 500 kilograms it would be a different
story
if it was a flight full of 500 sumo
wrestlers
who can weigh up to 200 kilograms each
it would also be a much more dangerous
stunt to pull during takeoff or
landing the plane has a much lower
velocity during those moments which
means that the shifting of weight
could have a more drastic effect on the
trajectory
and the captain might not be able to
correct in time
now if everyone decided to continue to
jump in sync
and at a quick enough pace you could
create an unstable condition
called flutter this vibration originates
from the airplane
causing unsteady aerodynamics which
affects the natural frequency of the
plane
natural frequency is the set of
frequencies that an object vibrates
at when hit if the vibrations from
passengers continuously jumping
caused flutter then the structure of the
airplane could fail
and you would drop out of the air but
the coordination of this would be near
impossible so
it's not something you really have to
worry about
despite many people's anxieties flying
is actually
very safe airplanes are safer than both
trains and cars although
if everyone had a personal airplane or a
flying car
then traveling by air might not be as
safe
but that's a story for another
what if
[Music]